his Kansas City Chiefs are heading home
to take on the Arizona Cardinals in week
number 10 they are sitting atop the AFC
West and he has the most touchdown
passes through the first three career
games two games of a season eight career
games youngest quarterback to throw for
six touchdowns in a game I could go on
and on about all the records that this
man has set please to have back here on
the Rich Eisen show but for the first
time as a professional we had him on
getting ready for the draft
Patrick mahomes how are you Patrick I'm
doing good how are you doing I'm better
for talking to you what is life like for
you sir
I mean it's going well right now we're
playing well we're kind of having fun
out here doing it and I mean there's
nothing better than that what's your
relationship like with Andy Reid Patrick
he seems to be sitting next to you every
time you go back to the bench walk me
through what those meetings are like
yeah I mean we have a great relationship
I thought we're always on the same page
he explains things to me so well that I
really understand it and can be
comfortable out there on the field and
so when we get out there and and we
we're together on the bench I mean it's
pretty much is also making sure that
we're on the same page we go over the
last Drive we go over things that we
want to do to try to exploit what the
defense is doing and we and we just do
and we go over kind of the plays that
are coming up next and I I feel like
that just kind of gets us on the same
page so I'm not surprised about anything
whenever he calls the plays so what he
said when you say that he explains
things to you simply that lets you I
guess
understand me on the same page give me
an example of that what does that mean I
mean just being able to know by the
coverages of the defense can throw at
you where the ball needs to go where how
you need to get through your read and I
feel like with that it makes us to me so
much more comfortable in the pocket is I
can recognize the coverage based off the
film study from the week and then as
almost like you hear that little voice
in the head of coach re talking to me
telling me that they play this coverage
we need to go through these reads versus
if they played the other ones and so I
mean just having that it gets me making
it where I can play fast in the field
and just kind of go out there and get
the ball in my hand and let those guys
make plays we always see Eric the enemy
talking to it seems like they're both
talking to you at the same time
what are you hear from Eric in your head
or afterwards yeah a B he's the one that
calls the plays and into the headset in
my ear so he
gives me this little reminders maybe but
on a play or he he'll let me know of it
they were and what personnel the defense
is in and it just helps me can really
just play faster be able to recognize
the blitz is more and at the same time
he's gone he's over there within those
means with me and coach Reid and coach
Kafka and and we're all trying to be on
that same page and you want to be as
smooth as possible whenever you're there
out there on Sunday
Patrick mahomes here on the Rich Eisen
show which of the 29 touchdowns you've
thrown is the one you're most proud of
because if I guess the way you read
something or the play that was made
which one of the 29 you've thrown so far
I think my favorite so far is gotta be
the one to Kelsey that I threw this last
week I just kind of put it up there and
I mean he made a great catch on it and I
told I suppose Kells I mean I he he
catch that for a touchdown and it looks
good but I mean if he if he doesn't make
that play on it and that DB makes the
play I mean it's an interception so it
just shows you the kind of the small
line that you have of being touchdowns
interceptions in this league is that the
one where it quieted the crowd except
for the fact you could hear him scream
like he was Braveheart in the middle of
the field Patrick is that ball on this
team I mean it's everywhere and we truly
just have fun doing it and so for us we
just go out there every single week and
get to play a game that we love and I
get to play with a lot of good guys
around and why do you think it looks so
easy for you Patrick why I mean I don't
all of it looks easy for me it's uh it's
never easy but I mean you have the guys
around me that I have I mean it helps
out a ton I mean it really is I'm not
doing trying to do too much I'm not
trying to make the huge play I just try
to get the ball in my hand and and guys
are making plays I mean Kareem had a
50-yard screen play for a touchdown
where you look on the plate the D Harris
has a blocker he puts wi all the way off
the sidelines and so I mean just
everybody's playing for each other and
we're all having fun doing it so I'm
wondering how you're handling the
success Patrick mahomes because every
Chiefs fan I know is out of their minds
excited and they can point right to you
as the cause of the excitement despite
the fact that you do have all those
great weapons and everything is clicking
it seems that the entire Kansas City
chief nation
just it wants to bubble-wrap you and
make sure you're crossing the street
properly I'm just wondering how you are
handling all of that newfound fame for
you I mean for me it's just about the
everyday process I mean no I mean it's
awesome there's had the passion of love
that the Kansas City chief kingdom has
and I mean it is truly special and
something that you can't describe in
words but for me it's you get to come
out here and play a game that you love
you get to play a lot of really good
guys that are really playing their
hearts out for you and so for me I'm
just trying to go out there and be my
best I can be every single day where's
the spot where you least expected a fan
to come up to you in the past few weeks
and they came up to you to say hello or
something like that you got a good story
on that front I know that I guess it's
crazy to me that I might have my hood on
at a gas station and everybody may just
recognize me immediately when I hop out
and then pump my gas and so that just
showed you how much these fans are truly
paying attention how much this cheese
Kingdom really believes and loves the
Chiefs so who do you think loves you
more Chiefs fans or people who have you
on their fantasy teams most definitely
cheese fans I mean I know the fantasy
thing it's pretty it's pretty cool and
everything but the Chiefs fans Chiefs
came in the passion that they have is
it's unmatched by anybody
what's your first sports memory Patrick
I think my first sports memory is when
my dad was in the World Series in
baseball I always remember that I don't
think I'm like five years old
and I just remember him being in Yankee
Stadium and me being at that at that
game and just in seeing it I mean I
don't remember every part of it I
remember just bits and part of it that
was the Subway Series right the subways
there were you there the night that
Piazza had the back thrown at him from
Clemens were you that was I was Bobby I
was in like the little kids room
watching the game my mom she couldn't
handle me I mean I was always trying to
play baseball all day long and so they
would kind of let me go out there for BP
they let me stay for a couple maybe a
couple innings and then they kind of
would just throw me in the kids room is
that where you met Jeter yeah I didn't I
think I met you at that play I don't
really remember it but I met him again
whenever my dad went to the Rangers a
couple years later than that okay and
a-rod is that a relationship that you
have that's lasting too even this day
Patrick yeah I plucked him a little bit
lately
it definitely as after
a little bit faded it faded a little bit
after my dad left the Rangers but I
actually talked to him again a couple
weeks ago through messages and stuff
like that and I mean he's a great guy
and I he was a great mentor for me to
have it when I was young okay where does
Nick name Showtime come from my
godfather Troy Hawkins him and my dad
but really him
everyday be watching play and I would
make the dive in plays and stuff like
that in baseball and they said it that I
was always it was so time when I was on
the field and so they always used to
call me show Tom especially my godfather
Troy Latroy Hawkins that is a name I
have not heard in a while
yeah yeah that's a Minnesota Twins
connection with your dad right yes
pretty much yeah
he came up a little bit after my dad and
my dad kind of took him under his wing I
think and then literally ended up having
a great career where he played I think
21 years in the big leagues I mean he
played that forever it seemed like and
he said in touch to him forever he still
comes to a lot of my games even now and
he's in someone that has been a great
another great mentor for me okay so
what's the what's the aspect of your
game Patrick mahomes few minutes left
with the Chiefs quarterback here on the
Rich Eisen show what what part of the
game has been the most difficult for you
to grasp do you think yeah I mean I
think just just the more experience I
get I don't know it's necessarily one
thing but the more experience I get I
realized that there's still so much for
me to learn I mean you you have some
success by just relying on just kind of
what the coaches say or just Talent I
guess you would say but at the same time
I mean if you want to get to where you
want to be at you've got to get the
experience and then learn from your
mistakes and so every time that I make a
mistake I know that I can't make let
that happen again I have to learn from
that and and and just keep keep
improving every single week so then what
mistakes did you learn from the first
half of the game in New England a few
weeks ago Patrick yeah I mean just you
you when you come out you can't try to
do too much I mean I feel like in that
first half I was trying to make every
perfect throw I was trying to throw the
ball hard as I can every single time
instead of just playing the game that I
played the entire year and I mean they
they showed me a lot of different looks
a lot of different um scouted stuff and
so I go back and watch the film on that
and just find a ways to not make those
mistakes early in the game I mean when
you play teams of that caliber you can't
make those mistakes
still win the football game you're a
gold guy do you write down goals before
season do you have that in you know I
don't ever write them down I mean I
think everybody has the same goal and
that's the Super Bowl but at the same
time I'd like its everyday process I
mean you can talk about it all you want
but if you're not put in the work every
single day then you know you're not
gonna get to that point you're not gonna
get the accomplish goal so are you
thinking about the possibility of
breaking Peyton Manning single-season
touchdown record of 55 you are
definitely having that in your sights so
far with seven games to go Patrick
mahomes yeah I actually haven't thought
about it really at all I remember being
at Texas Tech I had a ton of stats right
put a ton of numbers up and we just
didn't win football games and I really
thought after I left there I was like I
don't care about the stats I don't care
about any of that stuff I just want to
win and I was like that's the best thing
you can have is just winning games and
so for me if that all the stats they
kind of come with with kind of a job I
guess you would say and having this team
around me but whatever way we can find
ways to win games I feel like that's the
best that you can have is that a
reference to the Mayfield game from a
couple years ago that we were talking
about all week because you guys just saw
each other again this past week in
Cleveland I think if the reference is
kind of my hope my whole career attack I
mean we I've never seen we can never
seem to get over the hump and win those
big games I feel like we had the talent
to and I just knew that when I got to
this team and had all the talent around
me and a culture of what that was used
to winning games that uh that I was
gonna come in and try to win as much as
possible Patrick mahomes here on the
Rich Eisen show okay Patrick look I
appreciate you calling in here greatly
and I appreciate the text exchange that
I had with you the other day where you
were gentle in rejecting my suggestion
to give you a new nickname of the patch
rule I really appreciate that patch it
was a good idea I just kind of was
playing now the nicknames as much as
possible as I that point so it's okay
great so you're saying use you're saying
that it's not a judgment on the actual
creativity of the nickname it's just you
attempting to be humble tamping down any
of the accolades right now because
you're focused on winning is that Lee
yeah I mean just for me in general I
mean it's all about the football it's
all about the team and so I know that
the nicknames are cool thing to do with
social media and everything that's
around right now but for me it's all
about just being a teammate and someone
that's just a part of this organization
and a part of a team that wants to win
so if you had an ego let's just let's
just again let's put it in a box here
you have an ego you don't care about
being humble at all you're just you're
just pounding your chest nickname of the
patch role do you like it lately and I'm
just gonna kind of keep it that just
Patrick right now you're being polite
look it's been it's been a blast man
it's been a blast watching you just
these first few games and and it's gonna
be obviously an exciting finish for you
and the Chiefs fans are just nuts about
you man everybody I know just cannot get
enough of you the way you handle
yourself your business and you conduct
yourself under center and shock on all
of it Patrick Congrats on that yeah
thank you I appreciate appreciate you
having me too anytime I hope to have you
back on again
thanks again enjoy the week and we'll
chat down the line that's Patrick mo
Holmes at Patrick mahomes father the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience